para resumir este domingo en tokio 2020
debemos hablar de tres sorpresas fue un
domingo con tres sorpresas empezando en
la natación con la medalla de oro para
el tunecino ahmed have know we 15 se
colgó el oro en los 400 metros libres
algo completamente sorpresivo ganando a
los favoritos en esta categoría más la
fin de australia y quieren de eeuu la
segunda sorpresa fue la participación de
simón badass que comenzó en estos juegos
de toque algo que se esperaba mucho en
esta clasificación
individual en la gimnasia y sin embargo
se le vio bastante errática a la
norteamericana gran campeona olímpica
sobre todo tuvo problemas en sus
aterrizajes sin embargo esto no le
impidió quedar primera en la
clasificación aunque su país quedó
segundo en la clasificación las finales
que deben comenzar a partir de este
martes y la tercera sorpresa pues la
edad también el colombiano luís javier
mosquera quien se queda con la plata en
el levantamiento de pesas 331 kilos en
el total el oro fue para el chino lee
woon al ché y el bronce para marcó
sangre
de italia este lunes habrá nuevas
esperanzas de medallas para
latinoamérica en la final de mujeres en
skateboarding será sobre todo esperar lo
que puede hacer a pamela rosa una de las
grandes estrellas del skateboarding aquí
en el tokio y también hay que ver a qué
será lo que haga
adam y el británico en la natación
en esos 100 metros braza